sympa avec la banque centrale mais un ce
qu'elle fait c'est déjà parfaitement
illégal c'était pas le pack de début de
l'euro l'euro c'est la banque centrale
elle est là pour s'occuper l'inflation a
rien d'autre on peut discuter avec
michael chômage pendant tout ce temps on
a dit tout à l'heure elle fait des
choses vachement bien c'est juste pas
son mandat ça pose des problèmes dans
certains pays qui divergent de plus en
plus parce que 2,6 nous 4,6 l'allemagne
il ya des pays qui soit en presque à
0,05 hélas pour la banque centrale c'est
atroce que faire dans ce cas là attendez
au problème majeur de l'euro vous avez
une zone n est pas du tout homogène sa
divers de plus en plus qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait il faut qu'elles les intérêts
agissent pour limiter les prix en
allemagne mais alors on va détruire les
prix en portugal ou en grèce donc c'est
encore un effet qui est mal foutu mais
surtout très démocratiquement il y à une
soi-disante l'indépendance mais qui
décide de sa fiancée karma sujet majeur
ils sont en train de monétiser la dette
publique vous trouvez ça sympa avec moi
aussi discuté des avantages non mais il
ya des avantages mais aussi des
inconvénients et cette idée qu'on crée
de la richesse avec une imprimante
braille a quand même quelques quelques
décennies d'histoire montre que
généralement ça finit pas très très bien
en fait sur cette histoire là surtout au
niveau des prix ils ont déjà réussi à
doubler les prêts immobiliers on va voir
ce qu'ils font avec le nouveau
doublement la masse monétaire dans dix
quinze ans mais dans le cas de
l'augmentation à peu près de 100% depuis
mars 2000 20 de la capitalisation des
gars femmes n'ont pas doublé depuis mars
2020 ça aussi c'est une bulle bien sûr
seriez à l'injection massive hafsides à
alimenter des bulles partout puisque
finalement vous appelez gonflé d'argent
la masse des citoyens qui ont le plus
d'argent en beauté il ya un article à
l'école la semaine dernière qui montrait
que 1 grosse augmentation des prix des
super yachts à plus de 600 millions
d'euros à ba ouais c'est vrai gros
problème ou alors effectivement les prix
des voyages dans l'espace maintenant
aussi augmentent
[Musique]